well this year marks 30 years since
rookie of the year can you believe it's
been three decades
no no have your kids seen the film yeah
yeah
i showed my son pretty young or when he
was like three or four well your kids
are 10 and six when do they get to watch
american pie never
that was a look at the lyric video for
the thomas nicholas bands new single
1999 and the man behind the band thomas
nicholas joins me now congrats on the
single thank you yeah i'm excited about
this one 99 a good year it was a very
good year indeed let's talk about the
song it's between bowling for sue how
did you guys come up with the idea for
this track december last year we did a
movie podcast we watched american pie
right and it brought back all the feel
and so we're on stage performing after
the movie and he was playing 1985 and he
goes you know
we should sing lyrics about american pie
i was like that's a really good idea so
i you know sent him the lyrics he's like
that would be a funny tick tock kevin
just made a pact
while his friends react
that they all get laid before they
graduate and then i made the tick tock
and got a half million views and then
jared's like all right come to dallas
let's punch up the lyrics and
he's saying backups we worked on it
together he recorded me and going for
super behind me so it started with some
laughs yes well let's go back to 19.99
shall we i'll put this photo of you from
99. look at that youngin right there oh
my gosh you know 1999 was the same year
american pie premiered but what do you
remember about this time um i i remember
that earring
look i'm rocking it now by the way there
it is there it is i love the 90s um man
i i you know i remember the 90s as well
my gosh what i'm trying to remember what
this looks like it's from an event
because i look pretty like ready to go i
look red carpet ready like i said it was
the same year that the film premiered
and it also happens to be the same year
you first sat down with e.t so i thought
it'd be fun to dip into the e.t vault
and show you your first interview with
entertainment tonight all right
oh come on i really related to um to my
character's experience and that it again
it wasn't what he expected and they both
you know wanted so much more out of it
and now i'm gonna wait until i'm married
and you know i wanted to before it
wasn't like i wasn't going for the same
goal the thing is from that point
forward everyone's like hey is there any
questions that we can or can't ask we're
like listen dude
i was 18 right and everyone asked me
when i lost my virginity you you pretty
much can't top the embarrassment of that
in an interview well i was pulling that
up and i'm like times have changed
but i thought you would get a kick out
of that that's crazy so awesome well
let's go back talking about the music
you're working on your seventh studio
album so what kind of stories are you
trying to tell
um you know i just at this point and and
always just try to be honest and just
kind of speak from whatever i'm going
through at that moment sure um so you
know what's going on at the moment
there's a lot going on at the moment
there's a lot going on
yeah yeah exactly so i mean but that's
that's kind of like you know where music
can be a little bit of your own personal
therapy uh and then maybe someone else
needs to hear that same message and so
for me it's also about like being
positive
and finding even if you're talking about
something that isn't positive
finding the optimism in that and that's
kind of like my whole body is there
anyone on that dream collab list you
know maybe not for this record but for
the next one oh man uh
you know dave grohl uh would be amazing
we recorded our frat party album at
studio 606 okay but i've still yet to
meet dave wow uh but everyone tells me
that he's amazing yeah that's inevitable
i feel the energy yeah
but i want the meeting to be right like
i've seen him at like my favorite
restaurants in town but like not to play
like i could go up and get a picture of
like this is not how i want to meet dave
you're right um you know other than that
i'm just you know i'm so funny i'm
focusing on on film as well and so uh my
business partner and i actually just got
the green light on a development deal
wow
for something that we're we're
developing uh
with a studio so we're you know looking
at like a really cool film next year it
must feel really special to you to be in
this industry industry for so long and
be able to do all kinds of different
things and still going at it and still
having fun it looks like i really just
like to be in the creative space
whatever that entails yeah and you know
we were talking about before the
interview that my son is following in my
footsteps which is amazing um you know
with him being in m night
his latest film old as like the main kid
in that so was there a part of you or
like just wait a little longer just wait
a little longer you're too young no you
know it was all about i i started him in
acting classes just to kind of help him
understand how to
sort of control himself like in school
and social environments when he was
younger when he was six i think he was
really good
yeah well yeah he was better at it than
i was his first job was on new girl
playing zoe dashnell and jake johnson's
future forward son i didn't know that
and the very very last episode like that
last like few minutes that was him that
was him wow you must be so proud yeah
man he's awesome that's so awesome so
does uh do your kids go on the road with
you at all
no no
like the road is not a place that that's
the that's the work part yeah well this
year marks 30 years since rookie of the
year can you believe it's been three
decades
no no i mean technically it's been three
decades for me since we filmed it so
next year will be the official 30th uh
in 2023
and i think the cubs are actually going
to create a henry rowan gardner day no
and i'm like that's cool also why did it
take 30 years
what's your fondest memory of filming
that movie the first time i went on
wrigley field we hadn't actually started
principal photography yet okay so
i went out onto the field in between a
double header to shoot henry's first
walk from the bullpen to the mound
35 000. yeah it was the st louis
cardinals versus the chicago cubs
september 19th 19 1992 wow we'd just
been we're in pre-production yeah so
we're like hey we got this thing we got
10 minutes we're gonna shoot you going
to the mound like for the first time and
35 000 people are chanting henry and i
think for two minutes my name in my own
mind was henry that is definitely
something you never forget yeah that is
so insane have your kids seen the film
yeah yeah
i showed my son pretty young or when he
was like three or four and i remember he
like looked at the screen and said daddy
and i was like how did you recognize me
well your kids are ten and six when do
they get to watch american pie never
[Laughter]
no no and people ask me they're like
really never i'm like yeah i'm never
showing them that they they're gonna
have to watch it like someone else's
house well you were the wholesome
character sure i'm still not gonna sit
with them on their first viewing that's
fair that's right i expect to like get
that like really uncomfortable awkward
conversation so dad i was at my friend's
house and i saw i and then i'm like i
got a phone call is this well i can't
believe that it's also been like what 23
years since the first american pie three
years yeah i mean time is just flying by
huh it is it's insane uh do you still
keep in touch with anybody from the film
i do yeah we've uh you know we've been
doing like meet and greet events at
comic cons we've got san diego comic-con
coming up
so you know tara reed shannon elizabeth
mina savari chris klein
i've seen them all at different events
over the years
and then recently i was in new jersey
where eddie k is uh is living so i love
it it's so awesome that you guys have
been part of so many classics that
really do hold up like i mean people are
gonna be watching this for a while and i
hate to break it to you i think your
kids are gonna discover it one day okay
listen i'm not saying they're not gonna
discover it yeah just not with me that's
fair i think that's totally fair
[Music]
you